Please welcome Louis pelvic
[inaudible] on the show. Thank you for coming. Thank you for having me. Eh,
I was, I was trying to, to, to explain something to some people, uh,
who, who you are, what your music was like. Ah,
but I think you'd do it better yourself. Uh, when, when,
when with huge, huge posters, uh, in the,
in the English tube tube stations where you describe yourself as the
Scottish Beyonce. Yeah.
[inaudible].
Awesome. Wait, I know what we would all think him when I came out here,
I saw you looking, Oh, and you're thinking, Oh,
the single ladies, single ladies,
I put your hands up. You know what I mean? Um, so yeah, Scottish Beyonce,
and we're very similar.
Very similar. Do I do, do you worry that you can become too similar?
I bet. Yeah.
We both love to sing and dance. Exactly. We're both beautiful.
And we both love Jay Z. Excellent. But I'm definitely like she's married to him.
I'm not, unfortunately. Yeah, but uh, not yet. Not yet. Yeah,
no. Without a lot that manners will dissolve, but um, no, no, uh, yeah,
I was just, she's just, I just love her and uh, I'm Scottish.
And uh.
You know, when, when did you realize that you,
you become a great big star? Uh.
Oh, well usually, um,
I see other people answer this question and they see like, you know,
a big gig for the dead and stuff. But for me it was something much more,
it was much more like small and minute, but it meant the world. And,
um, I was in Glasgow where I live and, um,
I was having a few lager lager beers.
I don't know how you see that in Swedish. Well, thank you.
And um, yeah,
so I was drinking and then I was walking from one pub to another pub to meet my
friend and I, um, I thought, Oh no, I need,
I'm gonna need to pee soon. So I run in to the neatest, um,
convenience store and I go in and I say, Oh, I'm really sorry,
but if you got a toilet I can use. And they said, um, I'm really sorry.
We don't have, um, we don't have a public toilet.
Cause most of the convenience stores where I'm from door and I says, Oh,
I'm really sorted. Okay. Nobody's and as I was going to leave, you know,
potentially enter the world to pee my pants,
that one of the guys who worked there stopped and says, wait a minute,
are you lose capacity? And I said, I looked at mint. Yeah,
there's me. And he says, we've got a staff toilet that you can use. No.
When you are given the opportunity to use a staff toilet,
that was once that was once for bed that
You truly become, you think.
Truly.
[Inaudible]. Yeah, for sure. I mean, not,
not in like parks and anything like that, but I can do it.
FSR, FSR, staff, toilet and passenger.
So, so are you now, apart from the using the staff toilets, are you,
are you, are you able to enjoy the success?
I S you must not drink too much water because you know, what's going to happen.
Oh, that's good.
Stuff. I saw. I saw some pictures on your, on your Instagram.
Uh, this is,
this is you getting to number one in America and you
really celebrate.
I try and I try and have fun with it. I mean,
I'm allergic to face paint so that wasn't the best thing that I could have done,
but it was funny at the time. Um, but yeah, I think you have to,
you have to enjoy it, but it's because math, Mark, and a philosophy as that,
it's probably not going to last for very long. So just cause you're,
there's so many singles out there and I don't,
I've kind of squeezed by and no one's noticed yet like
sort of thing. That's what I feel like.
Is this what people call the imposter syndrome?
Yeah, I guess. Sure. I'm happy. I'm very happy. But, um, that we have,
but, um, I think, you know, if it does, if it all stops to model,
I'll know that I enjoyed it while it was here and I'll be less than it will be.
Well, a mess, a few things. Yes. Well, I miss being able to, you know, uh,
being, given some free t-shirts of course. Well, while I'm asked, you know,
um, people maybe smiling at me in the street when I walk back, of course I will.
Um, while I'm S passing and staff toilets. Absolutely not. I mean, uh,
but I thank him as, yeah. I just, as long as I'm having fun,
if I have as much fun with it, no, I won't be very outlook.
I know I'm not going to be sad when old disappears.
You're the opposite. When do you have too much confidence.
And the bedroom
[inaudible].
Yeah. Cause that's usually I'm at home. Then I come in,
usually people are sheepish bomb.
Here we go.
That's me mostly because I'm looking at myself in the mirror.
Oh yeah. And I think this is probably not, why should it be doing?
Yeah.
Um, you, you are as.
Some pictures.
Sometimes you can look in the eyes and sometimes I can look in the eyes,
but then, but then, then the mirroring is more interesting. Well,
it's just, I can't see myself in their eyes
or maybe you can. Yeah.
Um, you have, um, uh, you, you have this,
um, background from Scotland as we can hear from your femur language.
Uh you're you're uh, Dallas.
But that's a fresh Mungo. Yes. Salesforce mother is a nurse. She's a nurse.
Indeed.
Which phone do you, do you look the.
Most? Like which phone lists I look the most, like my mother,
which is a shame for her,
because you don't want to look like your son,
especially not one that gets told he looks like meatloaf on the regular.
No, nothing wrong with meatloaf at all. Love meatloaf love him too much,
but he has 74 years old.
Is it really easy to get on meatloaf? Yeah.
So people take you from me.
No people think meatloaf or Angela Merkel.
[Inaudible] that's fantastic.
Yeah. Well, I mean sure. For sure. She's she's a big team player. Yeah.
Um, but yeah, you know, I don't, I'm not, I'm not pleased.
I'm not Angela Merkel. No, no meatloaf. Yeah. No meatloaf.
So, but, but you, you still, you still live with.
Your parents. Yeah, I do. I do. Yes.
Is, is that, is that okay? I mean, nothing wrong with that.
Well, I go, when I go home, it's like, it's amazing. Cause I'm like,
I get free. I'm all never home. Like if I'm lucky three days at a time,
I think this whole year I've probably been home for about two months after that
a month and a half max. So when I go home, it's like,
my mom I'm like the best thing ever. You know what I mean?
They forget all my flaws as a human being and they just think, Oh,
it's our son and he's home. Cause there must be so much. And then my mom,
you know, washes my pants, my, I got my meals all cooked, ready to go,
which is lovely. And I don't pay any rent. You don't have to pay,
I don't pay any rent at all. Yeah. Unless, unless the tax man asks.
I'm counting on.
No one I'm joking.
When did you get.
That voice? Well, when, you know, uh, you know,
when you become, when a boy becomes a man
and you know yeah.
But they don't have good voices boys and man, it.
Doesn't, it doesn't happen to all of us. Well.
Um, some of us, I mean only parts of it have happened to me.
I'm still really upset about the don't steals and
I'm hoping for, I'll be a late bloomer, but no. Yeah, sure.
When I was doing pupil, not that puberty when I dead puberty, um,
that can, uh, you should try it if you have really good,
like a rasp in my voice,
but I never had it because I loved people like Joe Cocker and stuff like that.
And, and the lovely raspy voices. I mean,
I've probably done some irreparable damage to my throat over the time,
but who cares? It needs that.
Anyway, you have.
Off to, to sing for us later tonight. I have enough and yes,
I will do a sing. I will look forward to that.
Thank you so much. I
hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations.
Please hit subscribe.